language is a beautiful thing the human
brain has equipped us with we understand
and describe the experience of life in
the form of language it is the conduit
for transmitting thoughts and ideas from
human to human consciousness to
consciousness producing a worldly
vibration of interconnectivity but
languages necessity for human social
function has possibly limited the human
experience of life we seem to so often
forget that there is a world beyond our
current language a world of feelings and
thoughts that go beyond linguistic
comprehension did depression exist
before man created a term for it did
blue exist before man classified it did
anything exist before man identified it
if at one point in human history there
was no word for depression were humans
still depressed without knowing it what
did this unawareness result in and what
are we feeling right now without knowing
what to call it without being able to
identify it
or perhaps the opposite what aren't we
feeling because we haven't yet created
any words for it our understanding of
life and consciousness is facilitated by
language but our experience of life and
consciousness does not have to be
limited to it life is not solely found
in how you think or speak about it but
also in how you feel it it is this that
we must understand and try to embrace as
we navigate through life's unknown
you
[Music]